[Music]
this morning on the dish chef Kevin 80
born in upstate New York he started his
food career in Florida before joining
the kitchen team at one of the world's
most acclaimed restaurants the seafood
mecca lab Bernadin later he headed to
the borough of Brooklyn as executive
chef of Northeast Kingdom then in 2015
he and his wife opened Faro in Bushwick
focusing on house-made pastas and an
enlightened approach to ingredients
including organic produce sustainable
sourcing and whole grains a comfortable
local place it's Stiller notice winning
a coveted Michelin star just a year
after opening and in September he'll
open General Deb's specializing in spicy
Szechuan noodles
chef Kevin 8e welcome to the - good
morning good morning it's gonna be here
in here my pleasure
tell us what we've got on the table we
have some marinated tomatoes with
avocado house-made rye Pullman loaf some
chanterelle mushroom rescue Besh and a
cauliflower salad along with Scarpa rock
with a pork ragu we must ask you about
the drink drink is rye and ginger
that's the Bushwick buck with little
maraschino in it as well and topped off
with some soda it's delicious fantastic
you started out initially wanting to be
a teacher so right that is true my old
man's a teacher he taught history and
that's where I get my love of history
from and it ended up not being the true
love of my life so in the kitchen I went
so where where does this love of cooking
come from for you mostly growing up in
an Italian family you know watching my
great aunts and grandmother cook you
know from a very young age
watching them shower tomatoes make bread
and pasta you know roast peppers he just
kind of fell in love with it then yeah
and you actually would but by the time
you got to college you were I mean you
were you were cooking intensely in in
college in those years I worked at
I'm campus dining I was a little less
intense fine dining area dining you know
work in a place where the knives are
chained to the tables that's real safety
in the college kitchen a little
different than la Bernadette quite
different quite different what was that
experience like for you it's a very
eye-opening to work in you know with the
best you humbling go you know I was a
chef before I got there
I was running a kitchen I went there to
make salads and I loved every minute of
it I was surprised it took this it's
like one of the largest three three-star
Michelin restaurants in the world it is
busy every night you know busy night 320
covers which a normal you know
three-star Michelin place would be like
60 covers yeah you know so to do that
many covers that that high level takes a
lot of people a lot of organization a
lot of people with the same vision I
love your story about how you met the
chef Erik repair chefs great he's a
living legend my first day I thought
he's gonna throw me out of the kitchen
inspected my watch and he kind of
grabbed it you're right yeah he just
grabbed me out of know he's a ninja you
came out of nowhere
grabs me by the arm and searching
inspecting my watch and asked me where I
got it you know the guys wanted a Rolex
and I'm wearing a Timex so you're what
do you liked it and asked me where I got
I told my wife my wife got it for me
like she must be very smart
I said well she married someone who can
cook and dance so she must be doing all
right guys maybe she just wants you to
be on time before we go you mentioned
your wife you opened a restaurant
together you actually met in the food
business we met in the food business
when you're working a restaurant that's
usually where you meet people it's all
you do all your friends are you work
with all your friends we met 17 years
ago now we both have the same path
working for the best
we could work for was it always a dream
to open a restaurant together yep from
basically day one you know I I said in
the very beginning this is something
that you know I'm gonna eventually do
and she's like that sounds great
she runs the business she runs this is
the front of the house she does all the
wine and I just have to cook it's a good
thing that you do because it's the dish
we want to have you sign and as you are
Alaska if you could have a meal with
anyone past or present who would it be
be Carl Sagan I love that choice yeah
that'd be a great conversation I was
gonna say very interesting dinner
conversation for you during a long meal
we appreciate the time chef Kevin ad
thank you thank you and for more on
Kevin ad and the dish you can head to
our website at CBS this morning dot-com